alright hey everyone how's it going I
hope you are well so today we're gonna
talk about rejection it's the getting
told no getting shut down maybe even
being ghosted so I'm not gonna give out
any relationship advice because I know
when I think of rejection the first
thing that I think about is dating but
yo girl hasn't dated in a long time so
we're gonna talk about all the other
methods of rejection things like career
related and life related goals and
dreams related kind of stuff I was at a
summit last week speaking on a panel and
someone in the audience asked what do
you do when you get told no and that
really made me think a little bit
because I think I started having kind of
newfound perspective on it and I just
wanted to talk about it and also just
because rejection happens a lot in this
career and other careers and in life and
stuff like for instance when you don't
get an offer from a company for a job or
an internship that you want an interview
for or getting ghosted by tons and tons
of recruiters when you're applying for
jobs and when you're on the job - it
happens a lot because maybe you're
getting told hey you can't build this
this way because that's just not how
things are done or maybe you didn't get
to work on a project that you were
passionate about because of other
reasons and I don't want to discount the
fact that rejection feels bad it sucks I
know it makes me feel sad and angry and
frustrated and like I'm not worthy and
the imposter syndrome kicks in it's just
not a fun time and I guess what I wanted
to do was just to provide some
perspective and advice for how to think
about rejection so that it feels a
little bit more positive and
constructive have hope everything's
gonna be okay so my answer to that
question at that panel was if you are
getting told no then just be curious and
find out why there are lots of reasons
for people to say no and before you pass
any judgment I think it's so important
to really figure out what is actually
going on here which honestly is just
kind of a theme in software engineering
when there's a problem you
just fix it you figure out what exactly
is the problem so that you make sure
that the solution that you have really
does fit that problem and I think it's
the same thing for getting rejected it
is really important to process your
feelings and if you get told knowing you
know take a step aside or sleep on it or
something just to get the feelings out
do it it's okay to cry it's okay to be
angry just let that out first because we
humans feel things and we need to let
them out in constructive and positive
ways and let ourselves feel things so
definitely do that I'm not saying that
we shouldn't do that because we can all
afford to let ourselves feel a little
more because we are human after all
so once you finish processing your
feelings which i think everybody should
do and you should definitely take the
time to do that because that is
important work figure out why you were
told no like for instance something that
I often do and I get rejected for jobs
is figure out okay what was it that I
didn't meet in their expectations or
even what even were their expectations
what kind of person were they looking
for
where are my gaps are those addressable
gaps that I can talk about and fix right
away or are they things that I should
set as career goals in the future so
that I minimize those gaps or like when
I get told that I can't work on a
project and I kind of dig into why I'll
realize it's because for instance
there's like 20 other projects that are
higher in priority that are more
important for the business and the
customer and for people inside the
company than the one that I was thinking
about and then it makes me think like oh
yeah like no that's fair that's logical
that makes sense I internalize it and
then that kind of rejection fear and
feelings just kind of go away but of
course kind of doing the work to figure
out the rejection can't happen without
communicating with other people there is
a lot of work that you can do by
yourself and just to analyze the
situation and really think about it from
all different points of view but at the
end of the day it's most likely that
there is a misunderstanding or
miscommunication on your part or theirs
and that's why it feels really bad to be
rejected in my series that I posted
earlier this year I talked a lot about
communication skills so I'll leave that
in a card up above but
for now I think that there are a lot of
good ways of approaching this situation
for how to ask why was I told no and the
first rule of thumb honestly is to not
ask why or why not
straight up I think depending on how you
ask it those questions tend to receive a
response that is more kind of on the
defensive side and it's probably not
gonna answer your question super well
when I think about when I'm asked like
hey why did you do this or why did you
make this decision it feels a little bit
like I have to defend myself and justify
my decision even though I fully well
known that I don't have all of the
context or the background I'll just try
my best to make the best decision at the
time since they're asking questions
around the who what when and where are
more constructive so instead of asking
why or why not then asking in ways that
are like hey I want to know a little bit
more about how this decision was made I
don't think I have a full picture here
so I would really appreciate that it's a
much more kinder way of asking that
question also things like hey what can I
do how can I improve who can I talk to
to get more information on this those
are also really great questions because
they turn into action questions they're
more like hey based on the answer what
can I do like what are things that I can
do to get that yes or to really
understand what's going on here so that
I'm helping you and you're helping me
and we're all just working together and
collaborating really well and I think
the other thing that really helps and I
super value this is vulnerability and I
know you all have heard me talk about
this before but being vulnerable and
honest and upfront about hey I've been
feeling this way and I just want to know
exactly why because I want this
opportunity or jawed because XYZ and I
would really appreciate it if you would
help me kind of lets that other person
into the situation and and empathize
with you a little bit and like if
someone's being vulnerable with you like
they're most likely not gonna shut you
down and I think another important thing
to remember and all this is that most
people are not rejecting you or
no because they're malicious they have
great intents they're just trying to do
their job really well based on the
information that they have in this white
ambiguous world that makes no sense and
the resources that they have and so I
think getting to understand that world
read from them and kind of getting to
know the world that they operate in is
just as valuable and those answers will
come out when you really dig into why
did this rejection come why was I told
no and I want to end on this Japanese
proverb which is non knuckle Dobby Yelp
ki which means fall down seven times and
get up eight I interpret this proverb as
both a sign of resilience of yeah you
might fall down seven times which is a
lot but so long as you get up eight
times then you're gonna be back on your
feet the other interpretation I have is
around learning every time that you fall
and you get up you learn something about
how you fell and how you're gonna get up
again and you do that over and over and
over and over again and I think it kind
of speaks to just like that's how life
is you fall and you get up and you fall
and get up like you've been doing this
since you were actually little like you
were actually falling and learning how
to get up when you were walking as well
as just all the ways that you failed but
maybe you didn't even realize that you
were failing you're just learning so
much along the way from failure and
failure is not a bad thing so long as
you're learning from those failures and
you're taking lessons from them and
you're introspecting and figuring out
what you can do better next time and I
know it's really cheesy but people say
that rejection is a gift failure is a
gift they celebrate failure and I think
the spirit of that is true many mistakes
is not a bad thing you're trying I think
trying and failing is way better than
not trying at all because every time
that you try and fail no matter how big
or small you're becoming a better
version of yourself or at least just the
next version of yourself and we're
evolving we are changing as human beings
no one stays the same person for years
and years and years like that's just
life and I think it's okay to celebrate
that and embrace it
and as really bad and sucky and shitty
as it is rejection is okay and it's a
good opportunity to reflect and feel
things and figure out what exactly is
happening here because you're probably
gonna learn a lot of great things along
the way okay so that's it for today I
hope you like this video also if you
have future video ideas let me know in
the comments as well I'm kind of
planning for what videos I want to make
in 2020 as we approach the end of 2019
which is so wild how fast this year flew
by and subscribe if you haven't done so
already click the notification bell and
that's it I think I hope you have a
great day wherever you are bye